so with the 4th of july comes the legal
and unfortunately the illegal fireworks
independence day weekend one of the
busiest times for fire departments
nationwide
and last night no different here in
southern nevada hundreds of calls
overnight several serious fires at least
two caused some pretty major damage
bianca holman is live this morning at a
house fire near vegas and rainbow with
some of the damage left there
yunkan good morning hey good morning
john now that the sun is up you can see
more the damage that happened overnight
you can see some of the damage they put
up plywood right here in front of the
garage even that motorcycle that's in
the bay of the truck
damaged from the fire and there's a van
on the other side that's been singed and
damaged from
the fire so this is what we know so far
we have some video from earlier this
morning most the damage was contained to
the garage
we're told that there were no injuries
but the fire department is still
investigating the cause of this
situation so it hasn't been confirmed
that
the cause was due to fireworks but we
spoke with
a homeowner down in henderson who had a
fire as well and they do suspect that
was the cause of the fire
there in henderson so we will again
bring you details about that situation
coming up in the next half hour
reporting live from vegas drive and
rainbow boulevard bianca holman 8 news
now